merci arrachés depuis le président
mitterrand aussi parlé de la politique
de la france vis-à-vis des pays de l'est
et bien voici une illustration tout à
fait concrète en trois mois renault va
implanter un réseau en allemagne de
l'est pour vendre des voitures sur cette
chasse gardée de l'allemagne de l'ouest
renault a mis le paquet philippe rochot
lancement spectaculaire de l'opération
les 200 voitures des 200 allemands de
l'est qui vont représenter renault en r
d à ce rassemblement sur le stade
olympique où hitler avait organisé les
jeux de 1936 avait quelque chose de
provocant mais la régie renault a voulu
frapper très fort elle devient la
première firme automobile non allemande
sur le marché de la rda avant même les
japonais
elle prévoit de vendre 8000 voitures
d'ici la fin de l'année
devant ces 200 partenaires de rda
renault affirme que les allemands de
l'est pourront payer
il y a de l'argent épargné l'ivac caisse
d'epargne sont relativement importants
et lorsque notre une voiture aux
alentours
naturellement même prix quand
l'allemagne de l'ouest nous allons tout
de 16000 à 20000 marque
la demande est solvable les futurs
représentants de renault en rda ont tout
à apprendre des voitures ils ne
connaissent que la trabant mais il donne
toutes les chances aux marques
françaises pour conquérir ce marché
quand on compare les prix avec ceux de
volkswagen ou de mercedes
ils sont plus abordables pour nous et il
y a de bonnes chances pour que les gens
en rda achève ce genre de voiture
renault était la première entreprise
française en allemagne fédérale avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 7 milliards de
francs
avec ses 200 représentants en rda elle
va tenter de l'être encore dans la
future allemagne unifiée